what content goes viral okay let's go
through it
does porn go viral
boys watch a porn video they say bro you
got to see this this does porn get a lot
of eyeballs
yes yes yes all right what else goes
viral nowadays what else gets a lot of
eyeballs nowadays so stupid dances
stupid dance stupid pranks stupid pranks
what else
so you have to answer the question why
is all of this content about the
pensifying men going viral on platforms
that don't defend this argument meaning
Instagram doesn't defend what he stands
for okay Tick Tock doesn't support what
he talks about okay YouTube doesn't
defend and stand what he stands for the
core Foundation of those companies is
very different than the core Foundation
of what he has towards women because
they're more feminist they're more men
are you know the making men weaker all
that stuff but if these things are
getting this many eyeballs maybe what
it's saying is the market is sitting
around saying dude we've been waiting
for this for a while man like you know
the market wants to kind of have
somebody talk it doesn't mean it's true
or not but hey maybe it's what we're
thinking about maybe it's what a lot of
people are thinking about and that makes
some people uncomfortable to say no no
like the other day you know the the one
of my kids they were watching a movie
without my permission and there was a
scene in it
and my eight-year-old my ten-year-old we
have to have the conversation about you
know gays lesbians all this other stuff
I kind of shared with you how I had a
conversation with them when the moment I
had this conversation Jim walked out
she's like babe this is do you like to
have these types of talks I don't want
to have these ideas I sat down and I
gave him every possible visual they
could get so this is what's going on and
in many cases people who are not
teaching this because of Father Figure
is not in it we have to have this talk
you know what's crazy as much as I did
not want to have that conversation at
that point I love the fact that I was
forced to have it because I'm able to
get ahead of it so I can control the
point of contact and say Here's boys
what you're going to be facing a boy's
going to come to you and tell you this
this is going to be happening when it
does this is my uh this is what we do as
a David family so going back to you
if the algorithms are favoring a person
who they don't support his arguments
because most of these virtual
governments are more feminists left all
that stuff why do you think your
messaging got so viral well this is the
interesting thing because I didn't put a
magic spell on the world not a magician
you're right there's obviously a market
for what I say every people talk about
how I became the most viral person on
the planet I'll argue the point not only
did I become the most viral person on
the planet I did it while being heavily
shadow man they known about me for a
while they've been trying to shut me up
for a while I've been Shadow banned
forever so I became the most viral
person on the planet with all the
algorithms working against me unlike
people like Logan who have all the
algorithms working for them against me
because I'm resonating with people who
are sitting there going finally this
makes sense to me this is how I feel
inside and this guy's finally talking
about it everything else I consume is
telling me to do things that just don't
resonate with my truth I'm only saying
things that people agree with so to chop
my head off and try and delete me is
astronaut in and of itself because there
are billions of people out there
millions of people out there who feel
the exact same way this is what I was
saying earlier because and once again
I'm assuming the social media companies
have more have intellect and people who
work for them who are intelligent if
they were smart if I was a social media
company I would have come to me and said
listen
I would have had a board meeting and
said controlled opposition
and I would have come to me and said
Andrea you have to correct your message
don't want to delete you we don't want
to be censored we have to say this this
way this this way and slowly perhaps
paper me down on certain subjects that
would have been smart because they would
have come to you and said listen
and I would also talk to them and say
listen I understand I'm now the most
viral person on the planet I have to
take responsibility for the things I say
the way I say things for a video that
gets 300 views is different than the way
I say things for a video that gives
three million views I respect that let's
have a conversation I'm not a loose
canon I'm a logical actor they could
have done that but they were emotional
instead they murdered me and chopped my
head off and but that doesn't change
anything because there's millions and
millions and millions of young men who
think the same way I think there are
millions of young men out there who
don't want to wear makeup who don't want
to put on a Pokemon suit and be a clown
like Logan Paul who don't want to take
transgender blocking drugs who don't
want to uh assign themselves to any kind
of feminist ideas
who just want to grow up go to the gym
get strong be respected make money have
a beautiful girl in a sports car there's
millions of men who want that and I
speak to those men and I think these men
want something about that and they think
by chopping my head off those men are
gonna want something else because
they'll get rid of me and they'll put
James Charles in front of them and say
no foundation reviews it ain't gonna
work they don't want foundation reviews
it's not what they want and what's it's
it's truly crazy they think that's going
to work in and of itself at all you
don't think it's gonna work
I think I've been I think I've proven
that it's not going to work what's
actually the most upsetting is this
I find it extremely hypocritical and of
all the things in the world my pet
peeves the things that annoy me most are
hypocrites I find it extremely
hypocritical that the system itself
pretends it gives us [ __ ] about men's
mental health it will sit there and
pretend it cares about all the men out
there who are depressed struggling sad
but when I come along and tell them the
only way I've ever found personally to
be happy and contented because I can
only talk my personal story is to become
a man of statist to become successful to
go through pain to use my trauma to use
the bad things that happen to me to
Galvanize myself against attacks from
The Matrix as I've just proven I can
easily weather
when I talk about men's mental health
they delete I thought you gave a [ __ ]
about men's mental health I'm the most
popular man on the planet and 90 of my
content is like about women it's
motivational and antidepressive and
you're gonna sit here and delete me
saying I'm bad for women what about men
I thought you gave a [ __ ] all of a
sudden you don't give a [ __ ] anymore
right just delete him who cares I had a
man message me a man emailed me saying
that he was going to kill himself I get
about 10 000 emails a week I don't
answer all of them but I answer some of
this guy his email was so short that I
believed him subject was I'm going to
kill myself and the thing is I know you
won't reply I'm going to kill myself I
don't know what to do that was email and
I sat there and said listen my friend
I get a lot of emails I don't know how
serious you are I want you to make me a
promise
I'm gonna guess
that you're not in the best physical
condition you could be in
I want you to make me a promise you're
gonna get six-pack first and send me a
picture of you with a six pack if you
still feel like killing yourself after
that I don't know you I can't tell you
what to do but I want you to get
six-pack first email me back we'll start
going back and forth etc etc I convinced
him to get the gym I said get six-pack
see how you feel if you still feel like
killing yourself then I'm not telling
you to kill yourself I'm telling you
that's what I would recommend start
training by the time you start sending
me physique updates to them in a better
condition he started sending me huge
emails of apology and thank you saying
you saved my life I can't believe I was
thinking of killing myself you can't
believe you changed
that man would have emailed Logan Paul
with Logan Paul if given a [ __ ] would
have ignored do you think
yeah email he doesn't give a [ __ ] all
these [ __ ] media figures all these
people who are good for the system who
are dancing on the devil and [ __ ]
sitting here talking about dangerous
rhetoric and all the other [ __ ] you
think they'd [ __ ] answer an email
they don't give a solitary [ __ ] about
the young men of the world they ever
left that man to die and even if they
would reply to him what advice would
they give go take antidepressants and
watch my YouTube they have no value to
give the guy because they've never had a
life of actual genuine struggle I'm out
here genuinely saving lives genuinely
saying to men the world you now live in
is so competitive that if you're not a
competitive male you're going to be
perma-depressed you don't have a mental
disease you're just in a competitive
environment and you are losing you need
to become a competitive person there's
no easy way it's going to be hard it's
going to suck but if you get to talk G
the name if you get there it's a life
worth living that's what I'm saying and
that millions of young men are going wow
he's showing that you can be born from
nothing single parent on a [ __ ]
Council estate in the worst town in
England be stabbed come from nothing and
survive even end up with a
multi-millionaire I maybe I can do it if
I work hard and I'm diligent and I try
hard and I'm really giving hope to the
world and then they delete me then they
put up a new thing about men's mental
health saying which pill they should
take and then they put James Charles
offer him on the algorithm this shit's
evil it's it's genuinely Criminal I have
nothing but a positive force for the
world and this is what I was talking
earlier about the heroes Arc and the art
and the and the Redemption because I
think that inside of human consciousness
people are very very familiar with the
idea of of the Arc of a villain turning
into a hero it's in the Bible it's in
every superhero movie The Guy starts off
bad he's crazy he's too bad we don't
want him he's a Maverick he can't
control them blah blah blah towards the
end you're like where's Batman where's
Batman at and it's going to take a
matter of time before people realize you
know what Tate was actually a good Force
for the Youth perhaps used to create his
message perhaps he used to take his
Newfound Fame on board and change the
way he says certain things agreed I'm
not infallible as an individual but to
sit here and say I'm dangerous and I
must be deleted is disservice to all the
men of the world and then there's going
to start printing articles talking about
men's mental health they don't give a
[ __ ] about men they don't give a [ __ ]
about the 18 year old boy out there who
can't get a girlfriend is genuinely
lonely and the [ __ ] Sports starts
[ __ ] them all I'm telling him what he
has to do I'm saying listen bro of
course the sport starts locking them all
he's a g you ain't [ __ ] if you were a
chick would you choose you because I
[ __ ] wouldn't so whose fault is that
the best thing about being a man the
best thing about being a man is you get
to build your character from the ground
up you're not born with any value you're
born as a blank slate I decided I want
to be a big tote in kickboxing Bugatti
driving [ __ ] bad boy I did it all
myself you get to choose you want to be
a musician and be sensitive and play
guitar and get them that would be and be
important that way you get to choose who
want to go get in the cage you get the
[ __ ] out somebody you get to choose to
be anything you want but you have to go
and do it it's going to be difficult
because it's competitive but that's the
beauty of being a man the blank slate
and I Inspire men to look at themselves
as a blank slate and go you know what I
ain't [ __ ] now but I can become anything
I want how could I possibly give up on
myself
and then they delete me and then they
say we care about men's mental health
they don't give a [ __ ] they're lying if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
watch the entire podcast click over here
and if you want to be connected with
experts influencers such as Kiyosaki
Tate Connolly parliamentary myself and
others download the app connect where
you get a chance to connect with these
folks by the minute you get to buy the
minute or have face times with them 15
minutes ask them any questions you may
want to have download the app minute and
start connecting with influencers and
experts today
[Music]